So, it's a real pleasure today um uh to
have uh Lucas Byer um have a give a
guest lecture um to finish uh today's uh
uh uh lecture on on on the course. Um
Lucas uh grew up in Belgium uh wanting
to make uh video games on their AI. Uh
he went on to study mechanical
engineering
um uh in Aken in Germany where he also
did a PhD in robotic perception and
computer vision. Um I actually saw you
also work on like the Spencer robot,
right? Like Yep.
>> Yeah. So
>> and I also agree that to Russ is
terrible.
>> Yeah. We also wanted to ditch it.
>> Yeah. So I know Okay. So I think that I
guess that's the difference like he got
traumatized by by robotics and Ross and
then decided to pursue a career in
vision while I went to do like robot
learning like with end to end learning.
Um anyways um yeah then he later um
became part of Google brain um here in
Zurich uh working on a multimodel uh
team uh where he's done a lot of
impactful uh work like the uh vision
transformers uh we covered uh earlier in
the lecture
u or also like uh um like the cy cichlid
models um and polygeemma um that drive a
lot of the VAS uh nowadays or in the
last few years um and Uh yeah, now he's
at at Meta where he continues uh working
um on doing research on multimodel AI.
Um and uh yeah, with this uh let's uh
thank him for being here and giving a
big applause.
Yeah. Hello and thanks for having me. Um
good evening. So this lecture I will
mostly talk about the the part that
comes before. This is probably going to
be the least robotics lecture in this
robot learning course. Um but I think
you've heard a lot in the past uh
lectures about VAS. Um and a lot of them
actually are based on uh or all of them
are based on VLMs, vision language
models. And a lot of them are actually
based on a specific vision language
model polymer
uh which is open source model which we
released a couple years ago. Uh and here
I want to mostly trace you through the
history of like when computer vision
didn't work at all all the way to like
the latest uh update which was polyma.
So I want to tell you and explain to you
how things work before you turn them
into VAS uh and make them work on
robotics. Um and I think over the last
like I don't know 6 7 8 years we have
made gigantic progress uh in vision uh
in general and uh one example for this
it's not quite vision but it's a nice
example here you see the p uh you kind
of see the background picture you kind
of can guess this is Zurich right this
was actually generated by older version
of 03 imagen like precursor of current
image generation chpt
Um, I think I generated this sometime
last summer and five, six years ago.
This is actually who knows this picture.
This is what we were super excited
about. This was like the best generation
from a model by far. It was a huge jump.
We call it dog ball. Uh, and yeah, like
we went from this five, six years ago to
like this background just a year ago,
which is insane. Um anyways uh actually
as you just heard in the past I did
robotics or I always did perception side
of robotics and my personal long-term
goal is still uh to that there exist
hopefully before I retire uh a robot
that any nontechnical person can teach
to do basically anything uh they want
and nontechnical is important part here
like without programming please um that
way it's useful to as many people as
possible right uh And like maybe 8ish
years ago in my opinion what was needed
to get there uh was two things. uh one
is a very robust and general perception
such that you can teach it to do
something like let's say to put the
glass in your dishwasher with you show
it with one glass or you teach it with
one glass and it generalizes to all
glasses for example in all dishwashers
right uh and the other thing is that I
thought was learning from a few examples
you show it the thing a few times no
matter how like tele op video whatever
um and then it learns from that I think
now I revised this a bit because uh
language models happened and are really
Good. So maybe we can even teach it from
a few instructions uh only. But I think
still now robust general perception is a
key thing. Well and 8 years ago when I
started this journey vision didn't work.
Uh and so there was a lot of work to do
and actually learning from examples was
on pretty good track. So I went on to
work on vision. Um and one example of a
very good uh general robust vision
system is the humans uh visual
representation that we have in our
heads. Uh to show you what I mean by
this is here I can show all of you guys
this I tell you okay this is class A.
These five examples this is class B and
this is class C. And I show you a new
picture and by now you already know is
it class A?
Yeah class B. I shouldn't have said yeah
class C. Uh yeah, but this is easy,
right? But you also have seen millions
of flowers in your life or hopefully
otherwise it's a sad life. Um and
another one that you have seen less
examples of in your lifetime but
probably still a few is like satellite
pictures. Let's say these are all
pictures of class A. These are all
pictures of class B. These are all
pictures of class C. What class is this?
A B C. Very good. Uh you learn very
quickly from just a few examples, right?
But maybe you say okay you all have
flown maybe or seen this on TV or
whatever. What about this? I hope that
maybe half of you have never seen this
picture. Um here uh this is class A.
This is class B. Uh and I show you this
example. This may require you a little
bit of thinking. 3 2 1. Who says class
A? Okay. Who says class B? Ah almost all
of you have very good visual
representation. It's class A. Just three
things. no matter what. Uh but this was
slightly trickier but still like even if
you have never seen this thing before
like you were able to quickly learn
right uh this is kind of what uh I mean
and in our team back then we settled to
kind of try to
learn some things some model that is as
good as this as you guys at this
generalizing perception. So to make
progress towards that we need to measure
that and so first thing that we did ish
set up a benchmark which we call visual
task adaptation benchmark. Um so it's
basically the setting that you've just
seen. Um
where we say okay do whatever with
whatever data to get uh your model that
you want to test whether it is a good
general visual representation. Then we
come here from this abstract landscape
of all kind of reasonable perception
tasks and we sample a bunch of tasks
from all over this which just means like
get a long list of very diverse tasks.
Um and for each of these tasks we give
you a few examples to train on uh or to
learn from. Uh and then we have test
examples and you basically need to come
with some adaptation algorithm whatever
you want. For example, fine-tuning as
the most classical thing about you
anything uh and basically learn for each
task individually learn from the few
examples and perform as well as possible
on that task and then you get a score
per task average of this and this is the
score and we kind of want to make this
like we do research like the the next
few years are all research on doing this
how to do this such that we get as good
as possible score across the broad
category of tasks and that way hopefully
we and here climbed towards a general
visual representation.
Uh and then that's kind of what we did.
Um and I would say that nowadays we are
actually there. Uh we have this and the
general recipe. I think most of you know
this by now. It's like pre-train, mid
train, fine-tune, RL tune, done. Uh and
this is also the outline of the rest of
the talkish. So I'm going to talk about
pre-train, mid-train, finetune. And I'm
probably going to skip RL uh tuning so
you can not be late for dinner. Um so
pre-training I think actually I
yeah I don't even know how to ask. I
think everybody is convinced now that
you should just scale things right. Um
but back then it was not clear at all
and nobody was scaling things and it
took a while for the whole community to
get there. Um like in
Five, six, seven, eight years ago, all
the rage to try to learn general visual
representations was unsupervised or
self-supervised pre-training. So just
learn on images or videos without
annotations and just come up with some
task for example reconstruction or
future prediction in videos or whatever
um that you can have as kind of a
pre-text or pre-training task um and
then learn your representation that way.
hopefully it will be very general
because it's not biased by humans like
annotating this or creating task. Um and
there were a lot of self-supervised uh
methods. Um so we basically
reimplemented a large subset of them and
to see like which one is the best, which
one generalizes best according to like
this in this setting, right? Um
and then we kind of found out that
none of them is consistently the best.
But in each of them making the model
larger uh which is kind of what these
tables show or these
uh bars show like making the model
larger is always better. Like these are
different um methods and then within the
method the bars from left to right are
larger and larger models. Um and so this
was kind of not what we hoped but it was
kind of oh interesting of the tasks
themselves like the ways to pre-train
themselves are kind of all over the
place but for each one making model
larger larger larger seems to be better
better uh but still like the
self-supervised uh learning is kind of a
mess. Let's ignore this part here and
let's focus on that part and this is a
problem that I think also robotics in
general uh struggles with. Uh basically
the there is almost no correlation
between your pre-training task how good
your model performs on the pre-training
task versus your downstream task
performance of the model like how well
it performs on the thing you care about
after the transfer. Um so here on these
plots each of these bubbles are
different methods to pre-training uh and
different models uh that were
pre-trained. And on the x- axis to the
left, it means better at pre-training.
And on the y-axis to the top, it means
better downstream. And you can just see
that the bubbles are all over the place.
There's no clear trend. Uh except for
like same color bubbles, they get to the
top and right, which means keep getting
better at both things, which same color
means exact same setting, just make
model larger. So again like making model
larger seems to be kind of the only
thing that is meaningful for
pre-training here. Um
and however this is and this I think is
also maybe an insight that should
translate to robotics. Um if given it is
such a mess and no very strong
correlation across methods from
pre-training to downstream. Um so what
do you do at the end of the day? You
pre-train a bunch of models and you need
to choose one that you actually use and
deploy, right? Uh so you actually always
in order to choose one need to somehow
evaluate multiple of them and to
evaluate you need to have some examples
like either you have your validation
examples or if you don't you sit down
you look at what the robot or the model
does and say good bad and while doing so
you just write it down and boom you have
your examples. Uh so at the end of the
day you always have examples in reality.
Uh and so with this in mind, we then
thought, okay, then why not take some of
these examples, just a few, and throw
them into the pre-training and see if
that makes the correlation better. And
that's kind of what we did afterwards,
which is just take any of these
self-supervised label free pre-training
methods and throw a few very few
labelled examples into the pre-training.
Um and then everything became so much
better. Um, blue curve is without this
uh like how good is it on downstream
like training the this adaptation uh
doing the transfer to a downstream task
uh over time and like it really
struggles to get anywhere good but the
orange curve which is the model which
was pre-trained with a few examples in
the pre-training is just immediately so
much better easier to transfer and so on
right uh so this basically made us
completely discard uh self-s supervisor
unsupervised pre-training and decide
okay uh this is it we need supervised
pre-training uh and we need to scale
things up and then this is basically I
think this is one of my my second
favorite plot in my career um
here this is now going to fully
supervised pre-training so just try to
find however whatever a large data set
with a lot of examples uh that are
annotated like which in this case it was
classification pre-training so image and
class label for it like I don't know
picture of this and the class is laptop
um
and
here on the x-axis left to right is a
bigger and bigger model on the y-axis is
just how good is the model with some
metric in this case it was imagine a top
five um in few shot setting I think um
but it doesn't matter higher is better
uh and all of these pink crosses were
all kinds of different uh recent papers
back then which were all about scaling
up models and kind of what I want to say
here is like sure they get a little bit
better but it's not really anything to
call home about like going from 50 to 55
okay but it's not worth the making the
model gigantically larger which makes
everything more complicated more costly
slower um and we kind of reproduce this
with this orange curve which is making a
reset larger and larger and larger uh
pre-training on imageet which is a data
set of a million images. Uh however, so
it's kind of it's getting better but
very slowly as you make the model much
much larger. This is insane size
actually back then. Um however going to
this green curve and then to the blue
blue curve the difference is larger and
larger pre-training data and this is
like uh I think 15 times larger this
jump and this is another
uh 20 times larger I think. Um, so
overall couple of orders of magnitude
more pre-training data and this changes
everything like this dot here large
model on the largest data is just so
much better than everything scaled up
and published before. Um and even more
encouraging than this is there was a
eval data set which was called objectnet
which they take uh imageet classes and
just put the objects into very weird
scenarios like chair is a class and then
they just take pictures of chairs in
very weird locations orientations
whatnot like here is a chair on the
floor in the bathroom for example. So
this is supposed to test really
generalization to completely out there
images. The first image is always what
it looks like in imageet typically it's
very canonical and then here in object
net it's like what um and when we then
eval these models there we see the exact
same trend like here it's same scenario
but evaluated on this very
generalization out of distribution
testing um and okay I swapped the colors
of the lines I was sorry for that but
other than that like it's same thing
there is this is really really good
gener ization when you start training
large models on large data. Um so great
that that was basically one one
breakthrough that was like okay we
should do large scale pre-training. Um
then maybe now it's kind of obvious and
you're like yeah what took you so long
to figure this out. Um just want to show
a few reasons why it took the the whole
community a while. This happened in
parallel to it happening in the language
also. This was roughly the times around
GPT1 GPD2. Um and the same issues were
there and in vision. Uh one thing is
that it just requires insane patience uh
insane compute and also a lot of
attention to detail. Uh here is one way
to show some part of this. The red dot
is what everybody used to train on uh
ResNet 50, a smallish medium model on
imageet like 1 million example data set
which was large back then. If you then
just take this recipe and train it on 10
times larger data, you get worse
results. This blue point uh and so this
was there was actually I'm not sure
papers but at least several blog posts
about this like as negative result. So
people more or less concluded yeah maybe
1 million images is kind of enough to
pre-train and if we do 10 times more
things don't get better. Um so what it
and this is true like we reproduce this.
Uh but then if you also train like 10
times longer and another 10 times longer
then things start getting better. So you
actually need um are three things like
you need to make the model larger and
the data larger and the training
duration longer and each of these orders
of magnitude more otherwise you don't
see the effect of like large scale
pre-training being nice. If you do only
two of them you see much less of an
effect. If you only do one of them you
basically don't see an effect. Uh this
is what kind of made made it take a
while to get to that point. Uh
previously was my number two favorite
plot. This is my number one favorite
plot. Um, this was one of our training
curves. Uh, where you see, don't mind
this staircase thing. This was common
back then. Um, but gen like here, if you
look at this, uh, um, x-axis is training
time and y-axis is performance. And if
you just zoom into this little box, it
looks like this. And this was 8 GPU
weeks of compute. So like if you were
training on a GPUs for a week and kind
of looks flat any reasonable person
would say yeah okay let's stop this job
use the GPUs for something else. Uh good
thing we were not reasonable. If you
zoom out to this box which is 8 GPU
months you can clearly see no things are
getting better a lot right? So just keep
training. So that's the the thing about
it needing a lot of patience. Uh and
finally there is like I I say it as if
it was easy and so on. uh but there is
actually a lot of details to get right
and a lot of them are not obvious at
smaller scale. Here is uh one example
with weight decay which is one of many
training parameters um and just two
different values for this parameter. If
you just test them and have like two
preliminary runs and then you kill the
one that does not look promising, you
would kill the blue one even though it
ends up outperforming the orange one at
the end of training, right? Um so this
needs basically a lot of experience of
fiddling with these details uh to also
work well. Um all right but then like
this is convincing. Okay yeah we should
pre-train on lots of data large models
lots of patients large models lots of
patients we can do but lots of data is a
bit more difficult to get. Um
and uh typically all kind of
pre-training data up until then look
kind of like this like this grid.
Somebody comes up with a list of classes
and then for each class somehow tries to
get a lot of pictures uh usually by
crawling web or image search engines or
things like that.
Actually one uh anecdote that I like a
lot is envision this data set MS Coco
actually let me put some numbers in
here. First number is number of images.
Second number of classes. Uh this MS
Koko is super widely used for over a
decade in computer vision. Uh this data
set it has 80 classes.
Um does anybody by chance know where the
classes come from?
Yeah. Um so it's actually um
the the senior professor on this project
in the US asked his uh eight or nine or
10 yearear-old kid like what are things
that you can think of and the kid like
being an American kid was like
microwave, pizza, frisbee, baseball and
so these are the 80 classes and these
are the things that computer vision
community trained on like all uh All
detectors that you know are largely
trained on this data set and so really
good do typical 8 to 10 year old North
American things. Um and then that's it.
Um and yeah but but so always you had to
come up with a list of classes and then
sure there were more and more projects
trying to come up with more and more
list of classes and collecting data like
public imageet inside Google inside
meta. Um but in the end of the day
always bound by the creativity of the
people that come up with classes. Uh and
really the other approach that kind of
liberates us from this if we can figure
out how to train on this is if we just
flip this around and instead of listing
classes finding images for them we list
images. Like we just go through the web
list all of images and then don't have
classes for them. But what can we have
for them on the web? An image is usually
somehow surrounded by a text or like
some text attached to it. Uh the most
canonical example is add text in the
image tag. Um and then you do get some
garbage like this. This doesn't teach
you anything. Thumbnail for version blah
blah blah. Um but you also get stuff
like this. Uh these are real examples by
the way. Uh Frankfurt airport skyline.
So nobody ever creating a data set would
think of making this a class Frankfurt
airport skyline, right? But here you
have it. So you have the chance to learn
from it if you figure out how. Um, and
this is a huge breakthrough that clip
did. But I actually want to ask who
knows how clip training works.
Oh, very few I or like halfish. I
thought I could skip this, but I won't
because this is important. I think this
was like one gigantic breakthrough. Um,
and
it just enabled so many nice things. Um,
so how it works, you have these image
and free form text uh, pairs. You just
take a whole bunch of them, let's say
30,000, put them in a mini batch. All of
the images, you send them through an
image encoder and you get out per image
a vector of let's say thousand
dimensional vector. You do the same for
all of the texts that correspond to
these images. So your 32,000 texts, you
send them through a text encoder and you
get a vector out of it. Uh and now your
training task is in the
uh original clip formulation. It is for
each like for each text you have the one
image that it corresponds to, right? Uh
let's say this one and then you have
diagonal of ones and the rest of zeros
like they don't correspond. So you can
do classification task for this text
classify which of these image vectors
corresponds to it, right? And vice versa
for this image vector classify which of
these text vectors correspond to it.
Right? And these are vectors. So
classify is just dot product and then
softmax and then train this. And this
way you train image encoder and the text
encoder that kind of need to learn what
text describes what image and kind of
match these things. Um later we made the
cigip which is a simplification is just
binary. So same setup same you build
this matrix of text and images and then
just for each pair you say yes or no do
they correspond? Uh so binary
classification but it's again like just
dotproduct of these two vectors and then
sigmoid target 01 and that's it. Um
and with this this like opens us to
learn from this complete free form data
and to learn all the concepts we can
find on the web or we can find images
for on the web. Um I'm going to skip on
how to use this because it doesn't
matter for the rest and it works
extremely well. You just trust me. Um
so
I for me this was like a complete game
changer and it was like yeah now we can
actually learn everything not just these
80 classes from North American kitties.
Um but then what people started doing
with clip and I'm not going to name
names so I censored the method name here
but this is a very good representative
um is that they started from large image
text random data and then showed look if
we filter it down to this to that to
that we get better and better and better
performance uh and if you look at it
what was this filtering well first
filtering let's filter it to all the
words that appear in English Wikipedia
version Uh another thing Lion is one of
these uh open versions of these large
data sets. The full one has 5 billion
images but then all papers use two
billion version and 2 billion version is
the English only version of it. Um and
then it gets better like original clip
model which was released is then often
used to filter image text pairs like if
original clip model um matches them
gives them a high matching score then
it's probably not random noise but
something predictable right? So original
clip model would give this a low score
but this a high score if it knows about
it. So use this to filter it and
original clip model was trained on
English only. Um and it gets worse like
then they start doing stuff like okay
let's only keep those images which kind
of resemble the images from the imageet
data set. Uh and then yeah and the best
model is the one that has all of these
huristics for filtering. best model uh
measured how measured on imageet well
yay uh but then by doing so we're going
hmageet in case you don't know is also
very North American biased in what it
has so by doing so we kind of I really
didn't like this because we uh we now
just had this capability of learning
from everything or learning all the
concepts we can find on the web but we
kind of throw them in the garbage by
just filtering to English only imagenet
like stuff um and So we did a project to
analyze this in detail and in like try
to influence everybody who does image
pre-training away from this filtering uh
such that we get better general models.
So we did an experiment uh where we pre
pre-trained such a clip or cig model uh
on pre-training data filter to English
only versus keeping everything and a
very controlled experiment otherwise. Um
and then the English only uh model given
this picture would say this is the can
tower in Toronto when in reality it's
Mil tower in Thran and the model trained
on without this English filter would say
it correctly and same for this cathedral
which the English only model would say
is one in Montreal, Canada when in
reality it's one in Brazil which also
again the not trained on whole all data
not just English method would get right.
Uh, and uh, let's do one more thought
experiment. Close your eyes.
Good. Think of a toilet. Open your eyes.
Uh, you probably all thought of
something that looks like this. But in
reality, these are also toilets. Uh, but
you wouldn't really get these pictures
if you filter to North American uh,
data, right? Um, and there is a long
list of such examples. Um, and there
exists data sets analyzing this. So we
build a benchmark and showed that
basically as models get better on
imageet and the cocoa which is this
here. Um these benchmarks are very
correlated but then they get worse on
and then we collected a whole set of
benchmarks for like
for measuring how good it is on
basically across the globe things. Um
all right and then like we slowly I hope
kind of convince the community to stop
doing the filtering um and then we can
move on. Uh there is one
ooh time uh there is one more thing
um about clip and cig pre-training there
is a fundamental issue in this
pre-training that I just described um
and this is my favorite example uh take
this picture and this caption they are
perfect this is super clean data like uh
the picture perfectly described by the
caption uh now imagine this is in a mini
batch with a lot of other picture
caption images. And the task of the
model to of the training as I explained
before is for this image find out of all
of the captions the matching one the one
that corresponds to this image right and
vice versa. Um however to solve this
task if there is no other cat image in
the mini batch then it just needs to
learn to recognize a cat and the word
cat and it can completely ignore the
rest. Right? And same for dog. If
there's no other dog image in the whole
mini batch, then it just needs to learn
to recognize dog and the word dog and
that's it and nothing else. Um, and to
learn about sitting uh the model there
needs to be another image in the mini
batch where there is a cat and the dog
and they are not sitting otherwise it
can always take the shortcut. And to
learn left off there needs to be another
image in the mini batch with a cat and a
dog sitting but the other way around.
And how likely is that from random web
data even if your mini batch is like
30,000 or even a million examples. Uh so
this is the thing clip actually just
doesn't learn really these
relationships. Uh and then there were a
bunch of benchmarks that measured this
uh that were
created and we kind of wanted to fix
this in a scalable way because then what
people started doing is actually kind of
finding the counterpart and putting it
into the mini batch and so on and then
starting to enumerate things like left
off, right off and so on where they
won't try to fix it. We uh since um as
said earlier you should try to go for
the simple thing that scales. So we
wanted to try to find a simple fix that
scales and pre-trains but without this
issue. And there is a really simple one
which is just learning to caption like
generate the caption for the image. So
you generate word by word just like LLMs
generate text um right and when you need
to generate the word that comes after
sitting you need to generate left and
give it higher probability not right or
in front or behind and so on. Um so this
is simple um I'm not going to go into
the details but it sounds obvious in
hindsight the question is why didn't
people do it? In the original clip paper
there was a figure showing this is
horribly less efficient. um we were able
to reproduce this picture but it was
just an artifact of their exact setup
like kind of an accident of history. Uh
changed things and it's not horribly uh
less efficient. Uh and doing so then on
these benchmarks that specifically
measure the deficiency of clip models it
just completely nails them. However, and
here's the next lesson that is more
general than vision. And I if you take
anything away from this whole lecture
it's this. What does this benchmark look
like? Let's have a look at the data.
This is the key point. Look at the data.
Uh here is an example from this
benchmark. And uh given a picture that
I'm not showing you here, you need to
choose which of these two sentences
matches the picture. The sentences are
the horse is eating the grass or the
grass is eating the horse. Quiz time.
Who thinks it is the horse is eating the
grass?
Okay. Who thinks it is the grass is
eating the horse? you're funny once. Um,
so of course it is the horses eating the
grass. You didn't even need to see the
picture, right? And this is the picture
just for completeness. And the benchmark
is full of these. It doesn't make sense.
Obviously, you're going to nail this
benchmark if you have any real world
understanding. It maybe it shows that
clip models, even the text part, has no
real world understanding. But like just
to show it, we trained a blind captioner
that just learns to caption without
looking at the image and it also
completely needs it. Um so the key
lesson look at the benchmarks actually
because this is a very classical
computer vision benchmark mistake that
has happened almost every generation of
PhDs like there are papers and
benchmarks that are broken like this
like every 5 years. Um
and luckily there were other people that
also figured this out made the actually
proper version of the benchmark and then
uh also their captioning pre-training
just completely nails it. Uh so good. Um
and then just to say in future image
encoder pre-training models then we
always have a captioning loss because of
this. Um so if you know SIGLIP or if you
use SIGLPIP v2 is better and has a
captioning loss. So use that instead. Um
now I have an issue because I have just
five minutes for mid training and
finetuning. I think I will just skip
fine tuning. Um
and mid
Yeah, I'll just go a little bit over
time. People are hungry. Um, so mid
training is actually a relatively recent
term and people like this guy is
established professor and they're like
what is mid training? I think this
random person on the web uh I don't mean
this as an insult if you are here or
listening to this uh described it really
well. uh it's the steps that come after
the bulk of self-supervised pre-training
and are for shaping core capabilities
and before fine-tuning with RL for exact
behaviors. So it's if there are core
capabilities or I like to call them
skills also of the model that you think
will be really useful to doing all of
your downstream task or a large fraction
of your downstream task but do not
necessarily just come out of the
pre-training as you saw the pre-training
with image text whether it's captioning
or the matching clip style is kind of
crude right it wouldn't for example
learn locations like uh I don't know top
left or 2 m away off or something or
unlikely to learn this Um here and this
is the most canonical example of mid
training then that I promised you that I
will get to uh of the VLM right this is
a polygeema and most uh VLMs look like
this. You have an image encoder for
example clip or cigip that takes an
image uh sends it through and gets you a
bunch of vectors out uh which are then
you can just see as tokens. Uh then you
concat them with uh tokens from a text
which is typically some kind of question
about the image um or some kind of task
doesn't necessarily have to be a
question and then they go into a
language model and the language model
spits out the answer um or yeah so this
is for VLM and then VLA later instead of
answer it's like actions um and this is
mid training because it takes two
pre-trained models stitches them
together and then gives it new core
skills that will be needed later that do
not really come out of the pre-training.
And then the important part is what is
the training mixture of this? Uh and the
training mixture should be a bunch of
data that is reasonably large. Doesn't
have to be as large as uh pre-training.
Doesn't have to cover everything in the
whole world, but needs to force the
model to learn the skills that you uh
want it to. Um,
for example, I mean the simplest example
here is to just caption the image. Um,
but then for example, you could add OCR
in it. Uh, which is like being able to
read the image. Then you need to prepare
data that has pictures and then the text
that corresponds to it. Um, but then
again it's just to give the skill to the
model, not to make it necessarily useful
to a user to do this skill. So you would
just for example use have a ton of just
random images that have some kind of
text on it and the task is really just
to spit out the whole text and that's it
or just some random chunks of the text.
This in itself is not useful to a user
of the model but it it gives the model
the skill of reading text. All right.
And then later in the finetuning you
would actually turn it into useful to
the user uh kind of tasks.
Um
and uh yes and for this you will need a
lot less data. Um right and here in the
mixture there is some very special types
of questions also that are about
objects. Uh partially actually to make
polygeema nice for like robotic style
tasks. So it learns a lot about objects
and locations and so on. Um so is object
in the image which of object object
object are in the image and this you can
kind of semi-automatically create data
sets for this if you have some existing
images with some kind of metadata um or
turn question and answers around given
an answer generate the likely question
that led to this answer for this image.
Um and some detection some segmentation
data and also some like caption what is
in this specific area of the image. uh
for example, which again itself is not a
useful thing to a user, but it really
forces the model to learn a skill that
can be then repurposed in fine-tuning
for actually useful tasks. Um
all right. Uh and then in mid-raining
you can also use this or it's used a lot
to scale up a few remaining axis that
you were not able to scale up during
pre-training. For example, for vision a
very common thing is resolution. In mid-
training, you would learn higher and
higher resolution images as input where
you see more and more details which is
just not practical to do higher
resolution pre-training. It's impossible
compute wise. Uh or if you have video to
extend to longer and longer uh context
uh and if you were doing some kind of 3D
to have 3D task to have more and more
slices and so on. Um all right, but this
is only text out. Although I think you
have already seen how to get actions out
with VA. So this is maybe a bit less
interesting but for the classic vision
part you can of course turn a lot of
tasks into text output tasks and this is
the nicest example I think for detection
where you can really just split the
x-axis into bins um like24 which is
almost pixel locations and then you can
just output bounding boxes like this in
a textual way right with the coordinates
as text um and there is a general way to
convert almost anything you want into
text such that VLM can uh that you can
learn to model it with the VLM which is
the most common technique is called
VQVE. I don't have the time to go into
the details but if you're interested
look up VQVE it's basically your
autoenccoder which in the bottleneck
learns a discrete dictionary. So any
image like for example this segmentation
mask image you can then turn to into a
sequence of uh newly learned tokens. you
can just add them to your vocab of your
VLM LLM and then suddenly the VLM can
output segmentation masks by outputting
these segmentation tokens mixed into the
text. Um,
and yeah, I will skip the finetuning.
Uh, it's really just a large mix of tons
of specialized uh tasks. And the nice
thing is when doing the finetuning, you
also get kind of skill transfer of these
skills. So for example um you may have
learned to do segmentation but on
natural images like photos of animals
and whatn not uh and in your finetuning
you may have fine-tuned on uh let's say
question answering on satellite images
like is there a lake yes no in this
section and the model can actually
transfer some of these skills like for
example after this finetuning on a wide
mix of data the model can certainly
learn to segment things in satellite
images which do not exist as a specific
task neither in mid-raining nor in
fine-tuning here I can say for sure um
yeah and then you can do array tuning to
hopefully get even better performance
but we're not going to go into that now
um so
kind of concluding I would slightly
provocatively say yeah this recipe
somewhat solves uh perception now like
in the we have gone from 8 years ago
perception barely working at all to it
kind of being solved
Um
however if you are somewhat looking at
papers there is a bunch of papers that
kind of say like nope not at all vision
language models are actually blind and
then they give you for example a task
like this just everybody can do this
like two lines with a kink and the
question is how many intersections do
these lines have possible answer 012
um and then they test all kind of
frontier models it's a bit older already
So slightly older front models but still
on this end just showed that okay they
get pretty bad accuracy because a human
would get above 90% for sure. Um and
then they have a whole bunch of these
tasks and then so what am I even talking
about? How can I claim perceptions kind
of solved um the important part is that
this recipe that I just went through
this is what I mean by solved. You still
need to apply it for the things you care
about. Um, and then all of these VLMs
that they tested, they have a huge huge
huge list of SFT uh data sets in the
end. But obscure things like how many
intersections do you have these lines or
like similarish tasks are very likely
not in there because it's just not a
meaningful way to spend time to do the
post training mix. Um, but the models
can actually do this. You just need to
quickly explain the task to them. To
make this uh point, I took this task, I
generated 128 examples of it and then I
fine-tuned polygeemma on it and they get
95 96% accuracy already. And this was
super simple, super cheap. Uh and since
it's actually classification task, we
don't even need the language model part
of it, which can just fine-tune uh
siglip on it and we get like 97%
accuracy. So the VLMs are not really
blind. They are more difficult of
understanding like if you give them
completely new task. They kind of
intrinsically can do the task because
128 examples are not enough to learn the
new underlying skill of finding
intersections. Uh but they are enough to
learn to understand the task. What does
the user actually want from me? Um
so yeah. Um so this is the recipe. If
you have any task just think of the task
you want to solve. collect a couple
hundred examples in an afternoon,
fine-tune a large pre-trained model like
a VLM on this and then it works and then
if it's doesn't work well enough for you
then arune it and then you can deploy
it. There is a little caveat because
it's a little bit of bold statement but
I am careful to say perception task. Um
so I really mean pure perception. Now
the interesting things and those that
you guys will encounter a lot if you go
into robot learning is those that come
after perception uh like for example
adding some reasoning. So for example
this recipe is not enough to solve the
task of here take a picture of my
homework and just say solve my homework
there if it's non-trivial homework. Um
or explain why this is funny. Or if you
add some planning like this recipe is
also not enough to do planning. For
example, robot make me a cappuccino.
Sure, it understands where is the
capuccino machine, what where is the cup
and so on, but it this is not enough to
plan the whole sequence. Um, and yeah,
let's ignore the last point uh and get
to the conclusion for today. So, we have
this simple recipe now that the whole
community has converged to and it's
relatively simple. Uh, and if somebody
else did the pre-training for you, it's
pretty cheap. you can just take any of
the good recent VLM models and fine-tune
it on a small set of examples. You need
to tune the learning rate, but then it's
going to work um for perception tasks.
Um so now this is I really like this
because we can now move to actually
making useful things not just papers and
we can move to the interesting tiers uh
like planning, reasoning, uh actions. Um
this is a little bit unsatisfying uh but
it's not a blocker in that as mentioned
before just giving the text of a new
task explaining it in words uh is not
enough. We do need to fine-tune a little
bit on it to solve a new task. Um
and this same recipe okay this is a bit
older now because I made this slide last
summer but this same recipe is starting
to work in other domains. Language
obviously you all know this but also in
chemistry for example. I saw a paper
doing exactly this recipe but through
chemistry a chemistry sorry and working
really well. Um
so yeah then what is left to do I kind
of claim that this recipe is good enough
uh for perception uh and now we should
move beyond that and I think you being
here means you want to move beyond that
uh in robotic learning because that's
definitely a step beyond uh so yeah
apply to new task to new domains and
work on the things that come afterwards
like reasoning planning and that's it
thank
Do we have questions for us?
Thanks. A quick question like is there
any recommendation on the best papers or
like uh downstream toss um better do the
small scale pre-training not only like
bit kind of transfer learning or the
fine too thanks
small scale pre-train itself
>> small scale pre-training
I think is almost the oxymoron
no really um I think it really depends
what you want to do or why you want to
do it for but like small scale I would
say is not pre-training take if it's in
any way possible take something
pre-trained and then fine tune it. Uh
there is one thing if you want to try to
analyze and understand pre-training
dynamics you can kind of do it at
smaller scale um by it depends which
dynamics you're interested in. Uh but by
making
synthetic data for some specific task uh
you can just generate it and then you
can kind of have infinite. Oh, you want
>> quick follow up like then on the like
small scale of data just as we saw on
the like with the K kind of things
regarding these kind of like parameter
hyperparameters then on the small scale
of data even if I'm just doing the
finetuning process how to better choose
the like the process when to stop and
how to choose them
>> yeah um for how to choose the
hyperparameters even at smaller scale uh
the the good thing if you use a
reasonably probably well pre-trained
model as starting point in fine tune is
that type of parameters are less
sensitive which doesn't mean they are
not sensitive they still are um actually
for this you can check the polygema
paper like we do a very big study of how
to fine-tune on different tasks and like
what parameters are sensitive what not
we even have like a recommendation tune
this one first this one next and so on
and this is a kind of general
recommendation not just for balma um but
finetuning is relatively cheap. So I
would say just sweep the hyperparameters
and then it's very important to have the
to have a setup that you can trust like
to have a properly split training and
validation set. Make sure they really
don't overlap and so on.
>> Hey Lucas, thank you for the wonderful
talk. I had a question about image
augmentations and how much that can help
over actually collecting more and more
new data. And a second follow-up would
be how do you do data dduplication and
just making sure your data set mixture
is unique.
>> Yeah. Um okay. So image augmentation
it's always better to get more data than
to do augmentation only in the case that
you cannot get more data and do not have
enough then augmentation helps. Um we
actually have a whole paper on this too
which is called how to train your vit
which does a study exactly like if you
have uh 10 times less data but all kinds
of augmentations which one help and if
you have 100 times less data which help
how much and so on but the TLDDR is
augmentations can get you to roughly one
order of magnitude more data but that's
it. Uh and this is after very intensive
tuning of the augmentations which is
quite expensive. Uh so yeah if any way
possible get more data instead. And the
second part of the question was
>> dduplication.
>> Ah yeah dduplication. Um
yes this I don't mention it because I
feel like it goes without saying but in
all of our works we do heavy
dduplication. Uh there are multiple
things for dduplication. One is uh if
you have a held out set of tasks that
you use for testing or evaluating like I
showed in the very beginning this task
adaptation benchmark you should remove
all images that come even close to this
from your pre-training set. Uh and in
all of our experiments we did that which
is the only way we can actually trust
our results somewhat uh because
especially if the whole web is your
pre-training set then your benchmarks
are likely in your pre-training set and
you're not measuring the generalization
you think you are. Um
the and then I think
when we had maybe a graph order of
magnitude wise for each 1 billion
pre-training image maybe 10 million
would be near duplicates
uh of the downstream. So we remove them
but then if you have 1 billion removing
10 million doesn't matter much um in
terms of what you cover but it gives you
the certainty that your learnings are
actually real and not just the work you
think. Um then uh and how to do this is
a little bit difficult. We use the
internally trained model specifically
designed for that. I think there exist
some open source models also for that.
But otherwise just use a good image emer
and you get the vector as image
embedding and you can do nearest
neighbor search and do some threshold uh
and those that are near enough you
consider them duplicates and remove and
then tune it for high recall and rather
remove 10 times too much than too
little. Um
yeah,
>> yeah, thanks for the great talk. Two
questions, one more specific, one more
general on you told us a little bit
about the limitations of no matter how
you scale your batch size, you're always
going to have this problem with with
clip and and siglet. Um and going to to
Gemma, it was my understanding that that
the contrastive loss used there was only
on vision. Was that problem avoided
because nothing is frozen after it gets
fed through the uh language model
backbone?
>> Yes, exactly. Thank you. I wanted to say
it on this slide because it's very
important but then I forgot uh because I
was a bit in a hurry. Um but here uh
then this is a clip pre-trained model.
So it has all the limitations that I
just explained before. Um right and the
reason why not the captioning
pre-training model is just like big corp
technicalities. Um but it is what it is.
And so a very important part here was
exactly to not freeze this one and a lot
of VLMs that you find that are not
polymer have this one frozen so they
just cannot recover from the limitations
of clip. Um and this was very important
to us and we did a lot of studies on not
freezing it and specifically when you
start having things like uh question
with relationships or things about
locations like detection and so on. This
becomes very important. Um and this is
why like I I would not use VLM that say
they froze the encoder for anything
finetuning.
>> Thanks. And the quick second one, uh,
you you spoke to us at the end about
your approach to to fine-tuning um,
retraining models off the shelf. Do you
before you look to finetune a task first
see if it's possible to do it zero shot
or with in context learning and and take
some other approaches that require less
um, data collection even if it's only an
afternoon.
>> Mhm. Um, just because I forgot to finish
this is the training mix has captioning.
So this is how the learnings uh go into
the vision model. Now for fine-tuning um
I think in context learning is kind of
tricky. I think there have been many
papers going back and forth having
whether this actually works at all or
not. So I kind of just don't do this. Um
just prompting
yeah if it works uh then it's fine. But
then it usually means that there was
something similarish, not the same thing
but similarish in the SFT mix in the
first place. So you don't really need to
do finetuning. But then yeah, if quantum
doesn't work, then go to fine tuning.
And yeah, data is good. It just if it
takes an afternoon, just go collect some
data, sit down. It's annoying and lazy.
Not lazy, um, boring, but just do it.
>> Question.
>> Hi. Yeah, thanks for the great talk. I
think we all agree we could have
listened to it for like two more hours.
It's really interesting. Um I wanted to
ask you kind of much more general
question like if you have any opinions
on JA like joint in relative
architecture proposed by the main
>> that's just for context. Anyways, um so
yeah, I was wondering like if you have
any thoughts, do you share his view that
this is kind of the future and that
>> I have already that I posted at some
point
but yeah no like my opinion is that
exactly he did not introduce this like
this is what the people have been doing
forever in self supervision and then he
just like gives a new name to it and
maybe I didn't need a name because like
there was no name for it uh But that's
it. I think uh everybody agrees that
like this general direction makes sense
and we should try doing it. Uh yeah, but
I also kind of meant to ask if you share
at least the the hype part of his view
that it's much much um
high higher priority over LMS uh in
terms of reasoning capability etc.
>> Yeah, not really. Um
yeah,
because this is recorded, let's stop
here.
How much time do you have more?
>> For me, it's fine. I'm not hungry yet
for anybody here. If you're happy to
see, I will not take it personally.
>> So, going back to what you started with,
are there any plans to continue working
on the robot that any nontechnical
person can teach again?
>> Oh, yeah. It would be good. I still have
a few uh VMish things I am working on. I
want to see through and then after that
yeah
>> did you read the news that we acquired
some negro startup learning startup?
>> I guess
>> um one one question like um so you have
a claim that perception is soft. So I
kind of challenging a little bit there.
So there's uh for any like animals or
any like uh kids they can like
understand streaming videos like visual
content just coming through all the time
and um so understanding this streaming
video and react acting vision actually
like part of human was default
perception behavior. I forgot the this
kind of area is quite poorly in real
first you basically cannot streaming
understanding you have to like cap the
KB catch in some way to to somehow so so
it's and the perception system also
doesn't have the ability for example
like focus on really matters everywhere
like and filter out the non like matters
tokens all those I think somehow can
solve
So maybe I kind of a little comment on
that. Streaming video understanding.
Yeah. Uh I think for the I think there
is a few parts to this for the streaming
video understanding part. I think it's
basically a case of this uh that I think
there is just not that many questions
and types of tasks in uh in SFMix to but
I think fundamentally they can do most
understanding parts of video. Um but
there is the other part that is doing
this efficiently uh and online/ on the
fly. Um this yeah I didn't talk about
architectures at all here. Um this is I
would say
not solved but getting very close. Um
and uh
yeah and I think this is not I see it
more as a optimization issue. Uh like
not as in like oh write more efficient
cooler kernels maybe that will help too.
Um but it's more about it's not about uh
missing capability but it's about making
the current capability but it's cheaper
like cheaper compute or memory or things
like that. I think this is a generally
very interactable thing but I I will not
comment on like architectural details.
>> Okay you
>> okay thank you very much for the talk as
well. So
you say that all of this is basically
possible by leveraging web scale data
right and web scale data is still much
much larger than what humans need to
learn right do you see any way to reduce
this dependency on large data for
example for robotics or also other
domains where this type of data isn't
accessible
>> um yes it kind of depends what you want
to do um because I think If you want
like my goal that I mentioned the robot
to be able to learn anything then it
needs to have like seen anything like a
robot that has never seen a chair will
not be able to learn anything about
chairs unless we're going to continue
learning which is a whole different
question. Um
but yeah so I think if you want to be
general there is no way around it. Now
if you don't want to be general let's
say you want to make a robot that is in
the factory in the supply chain then it
should be robust to stuff like
illumination changes like I don't know
maybe the box is suddenly becoming a
different box because supplier reasons
or whatever um then I think this should
be very possible because then you don't
need to have seen shares like they will
not help you in your task at all so I
think it heavily depends on how general
you want the model to be. Thank you.
Um hi uh thanks for the talk. Um I have
one question is um is over there. Um do
you think there is still a lot to do in
term of infant speed because all these
large models are very capable of doing
great things for questioning and so on
and for robotic control or even drones.
Do you think there's still some work to
be done in this area?
>> Yeah, probably. Um, I think especially
if you go to VLA and then you have like
actions and like chunks and you want to
predict I don't know 50 or so tokens
into the future, this can be like too
slow to make it happen in real time and
there I have seen so I'm not expert on
this but I've seen quite a few nice like
papers and approaches for example I
think pi robotics had a few works on
that um and uh that's one thing the
other thing that I I wanted to put so
much into this slides. Um I wanted to
put in there but didn't is distillation.
I think this is also like a super
important actually. Who knows what is
distillation in the context of burning
most people. Okay. Yeah. Um I think
there is also like uh
how to say
like with pre-training you can do it
right, you can do it wrong. like there's
a lot of details to be careful of but
then if you get the details right um and
they respect us about this um then I
think discussion is extremely strong uh
and so I think a very very good recipe
or like let's say addendum to this
recipe that I mentioned is like do
everything scale up and so on to get as
good as possible model but then when you
actually need to use it nobody wants to
use this gigantic model that you need 20
GPUs to run on and so on um then go and
distill it for or like first do the like
pre-training to make it really good.
Transfer RL tune on your task to make it
good and robust on your task and then
distill it into one that has the latency
that you need for the task. Uh and this
distillation step can be very expensive
uh but because it needs very very long
training usually. Um but then it can be
very much worth it if it turns it from
to a how to say from to a broker from a
broker into hey we can actually do this
and run this on the robot or in real
life.
Oh and then there is million engineering
tricks and so on from the optimization
side.
>> Yeah. You show us that getting lunch to
do tasks requires training on like a
million different uh tasks in the train
set and doing a simple unseen task
requires a little bit of fine-tuning
sometimes. Do you think this is evidence
that frontier LMS have like a low fluid
intelligence as France would say and
they're just memorizing the steps to
solve a task and we need some like EBM
approach where you separate the goal out
of the model and put it in like some
energy function is more sample efficient
than just making more QA tasks.
difficult to answer. I would say it's
not necessarily clear that fining is
like the most efficient way or so. Um
and
so I I wouldn't necessarily agree that
okay energy based is the solution. Um
but I do agree as I mentioned this is
like the unsatisfying part of the
current recipe, right? That it doesn't
just understand what you want from free
form text. Um and I think there is a lot
of back and forth currently on how to
fix this. Um where like there is a camp
of people saying like not just do more
and more and more task and eventually we
have enough that it actually has to
generalize because it's just too much to
memorize. Uh which is kind of uh
happening in some uh regimes more in
text not in image text. Um and then
there's other camps that say like yeah
no this doesn't work at all. There is
also people exploring things like um
automatically generating these few
examples like based on the text prompt.
You can imagine if the model is really
good at language and at coding maybe
from the task we have seen here like I
just wrote little code to make this a
few examples to then train on you could
imagine maybe like a reasoning model
that starts doing this and so on. But I
I agree. I think this is the part that
is annoyingly not solved yet or would be
nice to solve in a nicer way.
>> Uh thanks for the talk. I have more of a
conceptual question. We're spending all
this uh compute and and amazing brains
like yours on how to make models
smarter.
At some point it's going to cost also
like the human brains. I don't think
we're getting smarter as humans by
outsourcing most of our cognition. Maybe
we're already becoming a bit stupid.
Like you think of maybe some software
engineers that have spent years becoming
extremely good at their craft and are
just pressing some okay keys um at 347
is not that smart. So let's imagine your
adult job unfortunately and your new
task is to make human smarter.
How would you approach it?
What the
>> the the human training after all these
trainings?
>> No, I agree. Like when I don't know like
Codex is down, I was like ah I cannot
work anymore.
Yeah.
No, I mean I don't know.
I don't have a good idea. One thing that
I like, but I think I'm just getting too
old to learn new stuff. Uh, but I think
the the L&Ms are just really nice to
learn new stuff with. I imagine old me
like 15 20 years ago, I would have loved
to have a LM there instead of needing to
Google everything, read like 20
territory tutorials and so on, but just
be able to ask it questions. So yeah,
that's kind of my but then also you you
have the calculator like you don't care
if you cannot multiply large numbers
anymore in your head because you just
don't need it. And could you outsource
maybe like you don't want to start
running something new today. Would you
be keen to have an AI lead you this way?
Do you think this is possible have an AI
like your sprink on everything and
knowing what are you smart on and not so
smart yet and push this direction?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I use a lot like this.
>> Okay. Okay. Last question.
Uh thank you for the talk. How do you
feel about um image encoders that do
weight with text like Dino V3 or others?
>> Yeah, I
not a fan. I don't see why. Um like
basically the text is there. Why not use
it? And I think there is I think maybe
DO is the only one that gets reasonable
performance at all without text. There
have been million of other attempts
before in this for supervisit area and
they are just always clearly worse. So I
think Dino is a
let's say I think it's a intellectually
interesting concept like huh we should
be able to be to learn uh like good
general presentation without text and so
it's nice and it's nice that they got
this far but I think it's unnecessarily
making it hard for us so
okay with this let's thank Lucas again
for a fantastic